bueno en esta ocasión tenemos Pues bueno
Esta carrera de autos que vemos Que
todos estos autos están corriendo por
esta pista y bueno Más o menos teniendo
una ruta
más o menos en este sentido mi pregunta
para ustedes es si suponemos que estos
todos estos autos van o tienen una
rapidez
constante
de unos digamos que 100 kilómetros por
hora mi interesante pregunta si ustedes
es existe aceleración
bueno ustedes podrían decirme bueno
tenemos una rapidez constante Si vemos
el odómetro de estos autos pues no se va
a mover de 100 kilómetros por hora en
todo este tiempo entonces pues si
tenemos esto constante pues uno podría
pensar que no existe aceleración Pero es
en este tipo de cosas cuando la
diferencia entre vector y escalar Entra
o se nota la importancia tenemos estamos
hablando aquí de la rapidez la rapidez
es una escalar si nosotros estuviéramos
hablando de la velocidad
de la velocidad Hasta parece pero no se
resuena V velocidad
Recuerden que la velocidad tiene
magnitud y tiene dirección Entonces si
estamos viendo la velocidad de estos
autos y bueno por lo que yo les estoy
indicando pues fíjense que realmente sí
hay una aceleración Aunque la rapidez se
mantenga constante si nosotros viéramos
la pista desde arriba más o menos voy a
dibujar la o tratar de dibujarla
pongamos que esta es una vista de pájaro
de esta pista Estas son las
líneas rojas de este lado más o menos
para que ustedes se den una idea de qué
es lo que estamos dibujando
o lo que estamos observando aquí tenemos
nuestras líneas blancas
rápidamente
para que sea una idea Aunque bueno no
está exactamente
a escala Tenemos aquí esta parte de
pasto verdecito
Tenemos aquí un poco de pasto también de
este lado y bueno vamos a enfocarnos en
este auto naranja que está aquí entonces
vamos a dibujarlo acá esta es como les
digo nuestra vista de pájaro y aquí la
ruta que va a seguir este auto pues va a
ser más o menos esta entonces la
velocidad que vemos que es una magnitud
Perdón que es un vector entonces
este auto Pues bueno va a estar teniendo
este dirección en este momento pero esta
dirección va a estar cambiando conforme
vaya avanzando para seguir esa curva y
para mantener o para hacer lograr Este
cambio de dirección
necesita acelerar para mantener su
velocidad llega esta parte digamos que
va ahora recorriendo así
y después
llega esta parte y va girando así
entonces para hacer este cambio de
dirección implica que así vamos a
necesitar una aceleración recordemos que
la aceleración sé que es un vector se
define como el cambio en la velocidad
entre el tiempo o el cambio en el tiempo
entonces la velocidad es un vector vemos
que en este vector que está aquí
Pues bueno es un vector que es va a ser
diferente a este vector de aquí y Bueno
nada más para anotar que lo noten la
longitud de la flecha va a ser la
magnitud del vector entonces estas
flechitas son iguales en los su longitud
representando que bueno son tienen la
misma magnitud pero la dirección en la
que están señalando es diferente por eso
es que está cambiando la velocidad estas
Este vector es diferente de este vector
y es diferente de este vector todos
estos están cambiando de una dirección a
digamos que hacia dentro de esta parte
de la pista están cambiando aquí por eso
es que hay una aceleración hay un cambio
en el vector durante un Rango de tiempo
entonces pues de esto se trata este
video esta pregunta un poco capciosa
pero es para que mediten en ello y
puedan comprender la diferencia si este
vector se mantuviera constante pues no
cambiaré de dirección y este coche pues
seguiría hacia acá en cambio Bueno pues
están dirigiéndose hacia adentro y si me
digo hacia adentro me refiero que esta
bueno la velocidad y la dirección de
estos autos Está girando hacia el centro
de esta curva vamos a discutir más
adelante con detalle estos trabajos con
los vectores en curvas y por qué es que
sí se está haciendo una aceleración
cuando estamos en una curva Aunque la
magnitud de la velocidad se mantiene
constante pero Eso lo veremos con más
detalle mientras Bueno les dejo para que
piensen y reflexionen en esto